[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now before we add any kind
of sign-in button to our
application, let's take a moment
to understand what's
going on underneath the hood
when the user signs in.
And that means it's time
for, ta-da, our
introduction to OAuth 2.0.
Now if you feel like you're
already an expert in this
stuff, you know it like the back
of your hand, feel free
to skip the rest
of this video.
But you must be some kind of
crazy genius, because,
frankly, I think this whole
topic is kind of complicated.
You could write a whole
book on it.
Come to think of it, this guy
did, and you should read it if
you want a more thorough
understanding of OAuth 2.0.
And that does mean for the
purposes of fitting this
entire topic into a 10 to
15-minute YouTube video, I'm
going to be over-simplifying
this thing in places.
In fact, probably to the point
where some bits maybe aren't
entirely accurate.
Also, I should probably
make this clear.
I'm no expert here.
I just happen to be able to talk
to people who really are
experts and then hopefully
I can pass that
information on to you.
But that said, this should be
enough for you to have a
general understanding
of what's going on
underneath the hood.
While all the nitty gritty
details of OAuth 2.0 are going
to be hidden from you by the
libraries we provide, I always
think it's just kind of good
practice to have a general
understanding of what some
library is doing for you
behind the scenes when you're
calling any of these
mysterious functions.
But if you do notice anything
that just seems outright
wrong, please let me know
in the comments.
I do read them.
I might even respond.
So with that disclaimer out of
the way, let's get into our
presentation.
So the analogy I frequently hear
with OAuth 2.0, and it's
one that I really like, is that
it's kind of like dealing
with a system of valet keys.
If I have a valet key for a
car, it probably lets the
valet, say, unlock the doors
and start the engine.
But maybe it doesn't let
them open the trunk.
So you can still keep your
valuables, or your bodies, or
what have you in there.
If you happen to have a very
fancy car, which I do not,
these valet keys might also
prevent you from, say, driving
over a certain speed or taking
it off any sweet jumps.
I mean, think about how
different "Ferris Bueller's
Day Off" might have been if
Cameron had just had a valet
key that he could have given
to the parking attendants.
Right?
Totally different movie.
Incidentally, in the world of
OAuth 2.0, these valet keys
also have the special ability to
self-destruct in a certain
amount of time.
So this valet better park my car
in the next 60 minutes or
he's not going to be able
to do anything with it.
The bright side is that if my
valet happens to lose the key
in the parking lot somewhere,
there's only a limited window
in which someone could find it
and steal my car with it.
By the way, these keys are
generally referred to as
access tokens.
They're also sometimes called
bearer tokens, meaning that
all the powers of this key are
granted to the owner, or
bearer, of the key.
Technically speaking, I guess
not all bearer tokens are
access tokens, but in the
world of OAuth 2.0, they
usually are.
So for the purposes of our
oversimplified tutorial, I'm
going to use these two phrases
interchangeably throughout
these lessons.
So what do these keys
look like in
an application context?
Well, you might have a valet key
that lets an application,
say, view the contents of a
Google Drive folder, but maybe
not delete files there.
In the case of Play Games, our
valet key gives an application
access to achievements, leader
boards, and lets them view
some basic user info.
But it wouldn't, for instance,
let that application view the
user's Google Drive folder, or
say, send Gmail on their
behalf, or use any other
Google services.
By the way, these specific
abilities that these valet
keys have are referred to as
scopes, and you'll hear that
term used throughout the
rest of this video.
So what does it look like if
you're trying to sign into an
application using one
of these valet keys?
Well, maybe you can think
of it a little
something like this.
Let's say I want to get into a
club, but the bouncer won't
let me in until he
sees some ID.
Well, I might say to
the bouncer, tell
you what, Mr. Bouncer.
I'm going to give you this
special valet key.
This key will let you open
the doors and the glove
compartment of my car.
It won't let you drive my car,
it won't let you open the
trunk, but you can get into
the glove compartment.
And there you can find, say,
my registration, which will
tell you my name, and my date
of birth, and maybe then
you'll let me in.
So let's look at this again in
a non-nightclub setting.
Let's say I've got my fantastic
new Angry Fruit game
that I've just added a
sign-in button to.
When the user clicks that
sign-in button, my application
is going to say, Hi, Google.
This is Angry Fruit, the game.
Please give me a valet key, or
an access key, that lets me
see basic user info, submit
high scores, and set
achievement progress.
The first thing Google will do
is present a dialog box to the
user saying, hey user, this is
the information that this
Angry Fruit app is asking for.
Are you cool with this?
Let's assume the
user says yes.
At this point, Google will then
give our application a
valet key and say, here you go.
Have fun.
At this point, by the way, our
application still doesn't know
who this user is.
We just have a valet key that we
know belongs to this user.
But what we can then do is ping
Google Services and say
"Hi, I have this user's
valet key.
Can you please send me the user
ID that's associated with
it?"
The first thing Google will do
is verify that the valet key
is valid, that it has the proper
scope that allows my
application to see the
user's ID, and
that it hasn't expired.
Assuming that's all cool,
it'll say, sure thing.
Here's the user's ID number.
And at that point, I have
an ID number from an
authoritative service that I
trust, in this case Google,
and I can proceed without ever
having to ask my user to set
up yet another user name and
password that I need to hire a
security team to watch over.
So let's take a look at this
request again, maybe a little
closer to the code.
Here's our request.
Hi, Google!
This is Angry Fruit.
Please give me a key
with these scopes.
And you'll notice I've added
another bit of information,
which is, when you're all done,
please send this info to
this URL that I'm providing
to you.
Now what does this call
actually look like?
Well, this part here, "Hi,
Google," or perhaps more
accurately, "Hi, Google OAuth
2.0 servers," is equivalent to
redirecting the user to a URL
that points here, to accounts
dot Google dot com.
Now this part where we say
"This is Angry Fruit," is
equivalent to adding a client
ID to this request.
This is a unique ID that
identifies our application.
"I want a key that lets me get
basic user info, set leader
boards and achievements," is
equivalent to adding this
particular scope
to our request.
You'll notice that our scope
looks like a URL.
Right?
It looks like a webpage
I could access.
There's actually nothing special
about scopes that
requires it takes the
form of a URL.
In fact, if you've done any work
on Facebook, I believe
their scopes look like just
plain old tech strings that
say things like email or
user underscore info.
I think Google decided to make
their scopes look more like
URLs partly because it makes it
easier to break things up
hierarchically.
You know, different product
can have different
directories.
And I suppose, at some point in
the future, we could set up
a web page for each of these
scopes that, say, gives you
additional information
about them.
But again, there's no rule
that says these have
to look like URLs.
It's just something
we chose to do.
Anyway, the final part of this
request, which is to send the
info back to a particular page,
is equivalent to adding
a redirect URI to the
end of our request.
So this big URL here at the
bottom, this is actually the
URL that we would send
this user to.
And it looks a little
something like this.
It's the OAuth 2.0 dialogue.
Now assuming, at this point, the
user clicks Accept, this
page would take a look at this
redirect URI, and it would
redirect the user back to a page
beginning with that URI.
But then we'd also need to send
across the access token,
and so we can send that along
as a get parameter.
This URI, by the way, will
correspond, or hopefully
should correspond, to a page
that I've created on my Angry
Fruit website.
It can grab this access token
information, either through
JavaScript, or maybe as a
dynamic server page, and then
I can start making calls to
Google Services using this
access token.
And we're all done, right?
Wrong.
Turns out, I just lied to you.
And why did I do that?
Why did I break this bond of
trust we've been forming over
the last seven minutes?
Well, because I want
to demonstrate a
security issue to you.
Now imagine that this
is my redirect URI.
It's redirecting to a page
that's not using SSL, and our
user is signing in from Joe's
Internet Cafe and Laundrymat
on some open-end wireless
access point somewhere.
But it also turns out that
inside Joe's Internet Cafe is
our hacker man.
I don't know why he's wearing
a ski mask and gloves.
It seems like that might make
him kind of conspicuous, but I
guess that's how he rolls.
Now this redirect, itself, is
still being sent securely.
All communication with Google
is being done over SSL.
But since our user's browser
needs to access example dot
com, it might do that over a
plain old insecure connection,
and our conspicuously dressed
hacker man, along with, say,
anybody else that decides to
view our server's web logs,
will see this access token
right there in the open.
And suddenly they can start
masquerading as our player,
because they now have a bearer
token belonging to that user.
And they can wreak all
sorts of havoc.
So there are a couple of
alternative methods that we
can look at instead.
The first way, and probably the
most common, is to send a
single-use code instead
of an access token.
Now this code can be sent down
to our server at example dot
com, and then our server makes
a separate call to Google to
exchange this code for
a real access token.
And it does this by sending
along the code along with the
client ID and a client
secret that
exists only on our server.
Now assuming all this
information checks out, Google
servers can then send back an
access token to our servers at
example dot com.
Our server can then make its own
request to the Google Play
Service, like getting
the user's ID.
And then it can send that
information back to the
client, which also gives us a
nice little benefit of not
needing to keep the access
token, which is a sensitive
bit of information, over
on the client.
It's just one less place
where our access
token needs to live.
But more importantly, even if
our hacker dude is able to
intercept the code, he can't do
anything with it because A,
he doesn't have our
client secret--
remember, that exists
only on our server.
And B, these codes are
only valid once.
After they're redeemed, they
can't be used again.
So he's pretty much
out of luck.
Sorry, Mr. Hacker.
But Todd, you're saying, what if
I'm a JavaScript engineer?
I don't want to spend a lot of
time doing server side code.
Can I just do this whole
"exchange a code for an access
token" thing directly
on the client?
Well, the answer is no.
And it's because remember, in
order to exchange a code for
an access token, we need to pass
along that client secret.
And that client secret
is supposed to
remain well, secret.
And if you were to keep a copy
of it stored as a JavaScript
variable somewhere, just about
anybody with a copy of Chrome
Developer Tools could
dig it out.
Luckily it turns out there's
another way to send access
tokens to a client if you don't
want to do a lot of
server side logic, and that's
sending it has a URL fragment.
See how our question mark
has been replaced
with a little hashtag?
You're probably used to seeing
these to jump to a particular
section of a web page.
But it turns out they
are also useful in
situations like this.
You see, URL fragments
don't get sent
across in web requests.
So when our user's browser goes
out to example dot com,
the request doesn't include
any type of access token
information.
But in the page that we get
back, we can run some
JavaScript that analyzes the
full URL, including that
fragment, and can extract
the access token
information from there.
Again, leaving our conspicuously
dressed hacker
man out in the cold.
That said, if you are going to
be using this approach, you
should do this using HTTPS,
otherwise a very sophisticated
hacker, probably one not wearing
a ski mask, might be
able to do something malicious
like serve up your page with
some modified JavaScript they
could read the access token
and do bad things with it,
or send it somewhere.
And that's probably
not a good thing.
So in a situation like this,
you should always use SSL.
In fact, use it wherever
you can.
It's just a good idea.
As long as we're talking about
security by the way, let's
bring up one other situation.
Let's say that my game is
incredibly successful and my
competitors over at Scammy Games
are so jealous that they
want to sabotage my game.
And so they create their own
game, and have their own
sign-in button, and their
sign-in button creates a URL
that looks a little something
like this.
This looks like a pretty normal
OAuth dialogue request,
except that you'll notice that
it's using Angry Fruits client
ID, but asking the redirect
URI to go to Scammy Games.
Now if Google were to blindly
trust that information, it
would bring up an OAuth 2
dialogue box, the user would
probably click Accept, and
then it would send that
information on to Scammy
Games dot com.
And if we're using our "send
the access token as a URL
fragment" approach, Scammy Games
would be able to grab
the user's access token.
At that point, it could trick
my Angry Fruit game into
pretending they were my
unsuspecting player, and wreak
all sorts of havoc with their
game, because it now has a
valid Angry Fruit bearer token
belonging to our poor,
unsuspecting player.
And we don't want
that to happen.
So instead, what we do is Google
keeps a database of all
client IDs, along with all
redirect URIs, that are
allowed to be associated
with this client ID.
So in this case, my Angry Fruit
game has a client ID,
and we've set up a redirect URI
that points to example dot
com slash OAuth 2 callback.
So now when Scammy Games makes
this request, Google will
notice that it's got a client
ID that matches something in
our database, but it will also
notice that the redirect URI
does not match, and it will
deny this request.
And Scammy Games will not be
able to grab a valid Angry
Fruit access token.
So at this point, I know we've
been talking a lot about web
games, but I know that we're
making an iOS game.
So what does this look like
in the mobile world?
It's pretty similar, except that
instead of a request that
looks like this, we're going to
be on a mobile device, and
we're going to ask the redirect
URI to point to com
dot example dot AF colon
slash OAuth 2 callback.
Now you'll notice this no longer
looks like a web page,
but this is still a valid
address that is pointing to my
Angry Fruit game
on the iPhone.
And that's because this com
dot example dot AF is
associated with my bundle
identifier in my application,
and I'll be registering with the
system that if you open up
a URI that starts with com dot
example dot AF instead of,
say, HTTP, or mail to, or FTP,
that should go to my
application.
Google is still going to keep
a database of client IDs and
authorized redirects.
And this authorized redirect
is going to begin with a
bundle identifier instead of
looking like a web address
beginning with HTTP.
The other difference, and one
that might surprise you, is
that you might expect that since
we're on a client-only
application, we'd be doing the
"pass the access token as a
URL fragment" trick.
And indeed, in many situations
on mobile devices, this is
what happens.
But in our case, we
don't do that.
We're actually going to pass
in a single use code.
But wait, you're saying.
We don't want to pass a single
use code, right?
Because in order to exchange
that, we need to pass along
our client secret, and you told
us that it's a really bad
idea to store a client secret
on a client device.
What's up with that?
Well, it turns out that when
we exchange a code for a
token, using a client ID that
we know is associated with a
mobile device, we actually
don't need to
use the client secret.
This might seem like we're
losing a little bit of
security, right?
Since anybody that intercepts
our code might
be able to use it.
But you have to remember that
now we're redirecting to
another local application on
the device instead of, say,
another web page out
there in the world.
And that's considerably
more secure.
So this all generally works out
in our favor, and we're
able to get an access token
back from our servers.
So now that we hopefully
understand a little more about
the OAuth 2.0 process and this
tutorial hasn't confused you
more than it's helped, let's
get started by creating our
very own client ID.
And we'll be doing that
in the next lesson.
[MUSIC PLAYING]